i think we can start chair okay
thank you charles welcome everyone to
today's meeting of the panel
if you have any technical difficulties
during the meeting then please contact
the democratic services officer on call
who will attempt to assist you
today's officer on call is katie brewer
and the number to call is 577-046
i would ask participants when you are
not speaking please mute your microphone
microphones must only be on if the
participant has been granted permission
to speak
to gain my permission to speak please
indicate on the chat and i will then
make a note and call you when it is your
turn
with everyone present please ensure that
their mobile phones are turned to silent
and that they are not used to make or
receive phone calls whilst the meeting
is in progress
please also refrain from checking emails
and ensure that you're in a quiet room
for the duration of the meeting
please note that this meeting is being
live streamed for members of the public
the meeting will also be recorded and
will subsequently be broadcast on the
internet
please can i ask the members of the
panel to confirm that they are present
in the meeting when i read your name out
councillor boyd
president cancer carmen cook
president chair councillor curry
present chair councillor hopkinson
council hopkinson council huxley
prison chair councillor pat moore
councillor pat moore councillor paul
moore
present chair council linda piper
castle linda piper
that's okay okay counselor ratigan
councillor ratigan councillor roper
here chair and councillor scott
uh president chair are there any members
who wish
to speak under 20.1
no i've not received any requests for
public speaking
apologies for absence were received from
councillor keane
are there any other apologies for
absence
i can't see any um are there any
declarations of interest
no i'll take that as a no okay
uh agenda item 4 pre-decision scrutiny
corporate performance refresh 2021-24
i'll firstly ask tim willis to say a few
words
thank you chad um hannah thorpe has led
let the um review of performance and
will lead on this item
but apart from thanking hannah for some
excellent work i just wanted to mention
a couple of things
first on relevance the aim is to
monitor performance in areas that matter
most to residents and businesses
and councillors the proposals aim to do
this whilst reducing the overall volume
of indicators
and second on reporting our past
performance monitoring has been
retrospective
and reported quarterly in future the
plan is to
produce as much information as possible
in real time always available on our
website
this will increase our transparency and
accountability
and will help reduce the burden of
responding to freedom of information
requests
i think these and other changes proposed
in a report will improve scrutiny
and we welcome the panel's views now
with your permission
chair over to hannah okay thank you tim
hanna welcome thank you thank you
thank you tim also um i'm just going to
present my screen
and can i just have confirmation that
that is working okay
yeah i can see it amazing perfect thank
you
um so yes thanks for that introduction
tim
um i have kind of covered some of this
at the previous session so
there might be um a little bit of old
ground being covered but i thought it
was just helpful to kind of represent it
again so it's in its full context and
then kind of aid our discussion
um at the end and i'd uh really welcome
lots of questions on this
when we get to that point as well so as
tim has said
the whole purpose of this refresh is to
modernize shake up and ultimately
improve the way that we
share information around the corporate
performance of the council
and this is really key and it's overdue
and we need to do this to make sure that
it links in with our new corporate
statement we've got three new corporate
objectives which are growth
communities and environment um although
i'm proposing
some kind of changes to the way that we
do things ultimately um the whole
premise of why we're doing this
and how it kind of sets the overall
vision and the kind of the context for
the whole council as a whole
and then feeds into service plans um for
each of the teams and then independently
into people's appraisals as well so that
everyone's kind of working towards a
common goal
and we're not changing that
fundamentally but we do
need now is the time to make sure that
we are
and keeping it as relevant as possible
and linking in with on
the the new um direction of the
corporate statement that is on our
website
um as i covered at the last meeting the
work to refresh this was delayed um due
to business as usual activity being
affected
and by the team and by other services
response to the kobe pandemic
and we're now picking this up at pace um
and
are aiming to go live with this and from
the start of april
so in terms of what we know and
understand of our residents they tell us
the same things every year
um although the order of the the top
three kind of chop and change and also
um we have just literally closed our
resident survey for this year so it'd be
interesting to see whether um it's the
same priorities again
but consistently for the last five years
we've been told that
feeling safe clean streets and having
thriving towns are the things that
matter most to our residents
and then in terms of the way the the
account the the residents expects
us to be in terms of the services that
we deliver they want us to be efficient
transparent trusted and responsive so
that has been the context for kind of
examining how we do performance and how
we can get the best out of
what we want to share with residents to
making sure that we're ultimately coming
back to what it is that local people
want
to be able to hold us account too so the
overall objective from an internal
perspective
is very much about trying to improve the
tools and the mechanisms in place
and to put to make life as kind of
smooth and as seamless as possible for
services
we don't want performance management to
be something that's like a clunky add-on
it should be
part of the whole part and parcel of the
way the service is delivered
it's really important that service
directors have got a keen understanding
of how their services are working the
areas that need improvement
and are able to then share that in a
really easy way and make it more
accessible
more important than that is from an
external perspective that we have got
the ability
to give reassurance to residents that
we're focusing on
what matters that we're doing a good job
in areas um and there
where if there are areas that need
improvement we're being open
up front and honest about that um and
making sure that residents can um
understand and access that information
to hold us ultimately to account
so in terms of what we're trying to
achieve from this whole approach it is
about
being more transparent as we've said
it's we know that that's something that
matters
um to local people and testament to that
is the number of freedom of information
requests
we receive in any given month and
actually by
taking on this new approach we're hoping
that we're just giving
more constant access to information for
residents in a way hopefully that will
be
a lot easier to engage with than kind of
clunky quarterly reports that are
looking backwards often and six months
kind of
past the time that they're reporting on
which obviously isn't kind of ideal nor
is it ideal for you as
a scrutiny panel we want to be lots more
engaging
and it's not just about saying look
here's all the information and then
having rooms and rooms of it to kind of
troll through and then
um kind of in so doing sometimes giving
the impression that we're trying to hide
things or confuse
and we need to make sure that the way we
present this is really clear
and easy to interact with um and easy to
digest
um we want to try to move away from the
numbers this is kind of focusing more on
the the so what
um i think we've got quite good at
presenting
um stats on kind of how many actions
have been carried out or what percentage
of collection rate
and we're achieving but ultimately i
mean what does that matter what does
that mean
to um the average local person they want
to be able to understand if they are
better off as a result of the service
that they are ultimately paying
us to deliver and so it's about trying
to demonstrate that what we do
um is is effective and that we're having
an impact on people's lives
so in terms of the proposed changes
these are all detailed in the report for
you
and i will just very quickly kind of
touch on each of them
so reducing the number of measures that
was kind of a key thing for us
again i appreciate that that might just
slightly
um given the line is around increasing
transparency but it's about trying to
make sure that we're
being really clear about the things that
are most important and
making it as easy to understand and
digest as possible
and we haven't been quite as um maybe
as bold as we were originally thinking
so we've gone down from 47 to around i
think it's 31 now
um so that's still a fair old number of
indicators and i think that's right i
don't think
we're in a position where we want to be
giving a message that we're kind of
cutting it down to say 10 and which
might kind of
give the wrong impression about us being
transparent but it's just about making
sure and testing that the information
that we are sharing is as relevant as
possible
for example do people really need to
know as we used to report
in the old um reports um the
our website uptime was 98 that was
written into the contract that we've got
with our web provider
um we there are financial penalties if
they don't meet that
it's kind of a given that we're going to
achieve that and it was again a question
of kind of also what
what you know what were residents
getting from us showing that information
so the whole way through we've
tried to constantly ask ourselves is
this something that matters
and why are we sharing it and as i've
already touched on
it's really important that we align our
measures with our corporate objectives
and the proposed way that we want to do
this on our website is um
visually to make sure that they can be
accessed through each of the objectives
just to kind of try to constantly bring
it back to that corporate statement
and show that's the kind of the
overarching statement of the overarching
kind of document
to hold the council to account we wanted
to
include new measures which demonstrate
efficiency
this is something that's going to be a
work in progress i don't think we're
quite there
um at the moment and this is what was
the previous um kind of statistics at
the end
of the report um so we know the
residents want us to be efficient that's
the number one thing that they've told
us for the last
few years in terms of what they're
expecting from from the council
um so we want to be able to be capturing
measures which demonstrate we're really
responsive and that we deal with
um with residents requests in a kind of
in a quick and efficient way
um as tim's already covered um one of
the the major changes with all of this
is publishing live data on our website
so it's
moving the focus away from the kind of
that although they were improved
i will admit i think we've done a lot of
work um over the last few years
to try to make the reports themselves a
little bit more engaging
moving to our rag rated systems of red
amber green trying to make it as clear
as possible
but actually having that information
live on the website means that you're
not relying on data that's then six
months old potentially
by the time it gets to being reporting
it um which is
you know doesn't reflect the council in
the best way and i don't think makes the
most of
scrutiny's time in terms of kind of
holding us to account with that as well
we want the data to be more interactive
as i've said already so this is about
um providing the ability for people to
kind of delve into more detail in the
areas
um that interest them more and so again
by presenting it against the key
corporate objectives if there's a
particular area that people care about
they can kind of then kind of drill down
into more and more detail
and again this will be a work in
progress and i think i touched on at the
last meeting that we're hoping to be
able to provide a lot more context
behind each of the measures and just to
try to give a kind of a wider picture as
to why
service is performing in a particular
way um
potentially controversial but i think
absolutely essential we are suggesting
that we remove
targets um sometimes like the kind of
the science behind the targets we had
before was a little dubious
it was a little outdated it was based on
um
previous um statutory requirements we
had a government level that have long
moved on now um and actually it meant
that the whole focus the conversation
was always around the percentage point
of a particular measure and again less
so about
what the service is doing and how
residents feel or how they're affected
as a result so it's kind of trying to
move
um away from the numbers and again more
about the
impact leading on nicely from that point
we want much more emphasis on customer
satisfaction um
and parts of um the area um
of the work we're developing that will
grow in the future is around
um customer satisfaction and so this is
going to be a work in progress
currently we do ask some key
satisfaction and feedback in our annual
resident survey
which is around things like clean
streets the waste collection parks and
open spaces
value for money that kind of thing as
part of this
new approach we've spoken to service
directors and
services and our expectation is that
there's going to be
more pressure put on them as a service
to have a direct dialogue
and direct interaction with their
customers um so that they're regularly
testing
people who are accessing their service
what they think of that service
so as an example people that are going
through um
a planning application process and it'd
be a bit pointless asking
in our general residence there like what
people's experience of planning is
because
probably a lot of those people haven't
gone through that process so actually
it's about saying to services making
sure that they're using their customer
base to regulate
regularly check in and regularly test
that actually the service that they're
delivering is to
an acceptable standard and finally we're
suggesting that we reduce the frequency
of reporting so previously we would come
to scrutiny
and then to cabinet every quarter and we
give you a very very similar report each
time
and i'd feel slightly embarrassed giving
you a very similar
narrative every time we met and whilst
it probably was interesting to some
people
i wasn't sure that it's necessarily the
best use of everybody's time
um so again this is this isn't about
trying to remove
the scrutiny and the accountability of
this process it's about making better
use of that time
so i think potentially um
when we'll be putting this into place
from the first of april i think
probably we should come back to you
after the first quarter and because it
is something that's new
and it will be really good to be able to
give you some analytics of how many
people are accessing information on the
website
and we can get some feedback about how
it's going
and we can share that with you and i
think because it's new it would be good
to do that
quite quickly um after but then i would
really like to open up
a debate with you about how frequently
after that you would like reports being
brought back to you
and arguably whether it's not me that
comes every time
my job is to make sure that the
information is being provided to you in
a really clear and consistent and easy
to
access way potentially it's
for service directors of the different
services that you've got an interest in
that need to come
back to screen to me and talk through
how they're performing and talk through
that
talk through things that are going well
or maybe areas that need more focus
um i know my colleagues are probably uh
not massive fans of that potentially and
but um no it's seriousness i think it's
it's absolutely right it's the way we
should be going um
and i'm still obviously going to be
overseeing this process it's just about
making sure that you've got the
opportunity to scrutinize the right
people
and put pressure in the right areas and
get access to information where i don't
then
say oh i'll get back to you at the next
meeting you need to have the answers and
that dialogue
um right there and then
so in terms of how it's going to look
apologies this is quite small and what i
will do um is make sure that this is
shared with you um after the meeting and
actually what i'm also proposing
is that when before we go live with our
web pages i'd quite like
either with the whole panel um or with a
selection of you
to get you to test it for us and i think
if you can navigate through and make
sure that it's all working as it should
that it seems to kind of work in a
logical way
um and that you think it's all kind of
looking clear and giving you the
information you need i'd really value
that feedback
um but what you may or may not be able
to see on my screen
um is that this icon on the left hand
side
there are four icons which represent
community environment growth and
efficiency
and as a user you would click on the
icon of the area
that interested you and then as you can
see on the right hand side that will
then take you into the layer of the
different indicators that fall within
that objective
um and as i was saying the plan is to
then to grow and develop
this section on the website and to be
able to provide more context behind it
we'll give narratives as to why we're
capturing
particular information how that services
is working and then link through to
relevant information that sits elsewhere
on the website
and just to give a full picture of that
service
i don't propose to go through these line
by line but what i wanted to
to show to you is to give you some
reassurance that in terms of when it's
come to each of the
measures that we want to capture which
is in appendix one
what we've done with each of the service
directors is we've asked them to
give us the name of the measure to
explain specifically what is being
captured
as part of that target as part of that
indicator sorry
answer question why it's being measured
so that we can test and be really sure
that we're capturing it for a reason
that's going to have a benefit for local
people
something that we're also working on
currently is also establishing what good
looks like
for each of those um indicators so
because we're moving
the removing the targets or proposing to
remove the targets
what we wanted to do was to then
establish what we consider to be an
acceptable or a good baseline
of what you can what we would expect of
ourselves in terms of delivering that
service
we can represent that then potentially
on the graph as a line that we wouldn't
want to go below
if we did dip below it then you could be
holding us to account and asking why and
what steps have been put in place
um but we felt that that was a kind of a
better way of
presenting um how we are doing as a
council rather than
um the targets and so we've done that
for each of communities growth
uh environment and efficiency so i wish
through these but i will share this with
you afterwards
so um in terms of next steps um we have
a performer like a corporate performance
management framework that sits behind
this
and this is something that gets audited
um as part of our internal audit
process at the council and we've tried
to take on feedback from previous audits
as part of this
new regime and we need to update that
and that's something it's an internal
document but i'd be happy if there are
scrutiny panel members who would be
interested to see that i see no reason
why we wouldn't want to share that with
you
and that just sets out how this links
with appraisals how it links with
service planning
and just kind of making it really clear
about how it will all
work and kind of what the time scales
are around it we'd really like your
input
it'll be going to cabinet next as well
um but
i'm kind of willing and welcome in fact
um as many questions
as you've got in relation to this
process and the individual measures as
well
um there might be things on in appendix
one that potentially you were surprised
not to see
or the question why we have included it
and i'd really welcome feedback on that
and our next steps once we've got that
steer from you will be to finalize the
development of the website
and like i said i'm really keen to make
sure that we do some user testing with
you
um just to make sure that it's working
in a way that you think
is um is good and is positive we then
seek to implement it from the first of
april
and we intend to have it in place for
the next four years so it will see
through the life of the corporate
statement
but it will also cover us at the end so
when the current corporate statement
runs out in 2023
it gives us um 12 months whilst the new
corporate statement is being developed
um it still means that we can be held to
account um
in the meantime and the final thing that
i just wanted to update on
before i in the presentation and take
any questions
one of the bits of feedback that i got
probably the most
from scrutiny in relation to the
previous indicators
was in relation to the clean streets
indicator so
obviously clean streets is the one of
the things that matters most
to you as councillors and to local
people and we wanted to improve
the way that we monitor it it was always
considered to be a very clunky
um way that we managed it before it was
based on something called ni 195
um for any kind of geeks out there like
myself um
and that was previous government
statutory
guidance in terms of how you collect
data and how that's presented and
recorded in terms of
um how particular areas of the streets
look um
and that's what we put presented against
in these reports um
it is really clunky it wasn't ideal it
was monitored actually by people within
operational services so it's kind of
um potentially as audit pointed out to
us people marking their own homework
um so what we have agreed um with all of
the different service directors
blessings
um is that we're gonna roll out um the
analysis
and across each of the different service
direct directorates
um at the council everyone's going to
contribute to that they'll have to be
trained there'll be a very particular
way of doing it
but we'll be monitoring and mapping and
particular street areas
um a much kind of lower level and
actually what i'm going
to do and with nathaniel's permission
i've got my colleague nathaniel
um with me nathaniel fisher and he has
been working
with mike humber to develop this new way
of recording this information
with chair with your permission can i um
bring the final win just to give a
little bit more context to that
particular measure
yeah absolutely yeah welcome i'm gonna
stop presenting and i'll hand over to
you if that's okay
sorry done the classic of talking while
on me and thank you hannah
i think when trying to explain the old
indicators it kind of was very backwards
we had to say
how many streets were at an acceptable
level and it was confusing for residents
and confusing for staff and probably
confusing for councillors as well
so what we've looked at doing mike and
myself
is carving up the district into small
squares or smallish squares and then
according to where the populations are
focusing on those areas
to make sure that the streets are clean
and
using as hannah said this survey which
will
look at four different main areas so
litter graffiti detritus
and dog fowling um it'll be a simple
form
where people can follow uh what
what the good standards of those
different things are
and then also attach a photo as well so
it's not a case that
um there's any any sort of underhand
marking of work as hannah mentioned
and that they could be looked back to a
picture and then
give an indication of how clean the
streets are
across the district which i think could
be really exciting
a bit of information where we can then
focus
with that information where the streets
need to be cleaned and hopefully
and next year's resident survey
there'll be a marked change in how
the public's perception of the area is
as well
thanks nathaniel and am i right in
saying as well nathaniel the um one of
the tools that we can use as part of
this is then being able to do almost
like a heat map
where we can look at the district and
identify kind of our hotspot areas now
i'm sure we all kind of think in our
minds that we know where that might be
but actually i think we need to have the
evidence to back that up
and and that is again the kind of the
level of information we hope to be able
to share with you with scrutiny
and so rather kind of than meaningless
potentially and stats about what's
acceptable or not we will have kind of
a lot more intelligence to to share um
and to be able to give you
level that kind of uh even lower than a
dish even lower than award level i think
they call it middle super output
level i think that's what it is um but
anyway yes we'll do all of that and
we'll make sure it's all clear
and explained really well to you as a
result but um
that was as much talking as i was going
to do and you've obviously had the
report
um and i'm really happy to take any
further questions thank you
okay members uh if you would like to
make any comment or got a question could
you indicate in the chat please
um i'd just like to make a couple of
points so i
i like the notion that you're going to
trial it with us on the basis that if we
can use it anyone can
i think that's you know that that's a
good start
um and uh i don't what you're saying
passing i don't know if it was anywhere
else but
the appendix one that i've got it's got
the measure name what is being measured
but the
justification for the measurements not
on there it just says the section it
comes under
and that would have been quite useful
just as you were presenting that
you know it answered quite a lot of
questions that were being raised in my
mind so
if you could share that with members
afterwards that would be really good
okay um right first of all um
councillor paul moore yes thank you
chair i think you've just stolen my
thunder
because i was going to ask that very
question about um
how we've come to those solutions
um my main one was in appendix one
the time scale for the houses being
empty the six month period um
it would be nice to know how we've come
to that time scale uh
and and what what the benchmark was for
so if hannah could let us know that or
give some feedback that'd be fantastic
thank you chair okay hannah do you want
to address that now do you just want to
take a list and
the feedback maybe at the end any ones
that you can answer now and
come back in writing on any others yeah
yeah that would be great thank you
okay all right we'll move on um
councillor curry
thank you chair yeah thanks for the
presentations um
uh yeah i i think it's a really um good
idea the plan to present the performance
data live on the website
i think this would help members
and residents um we'll be fully updated
relevant information you know we can
whenever we get contacted by uh
residents in particular
what i would like to ask is um would or
will enforcement action and fines be
added to the
data published we get a lot of um
contact with residents reporting flight
tipping and so on
but they sometimes do ask you know has
any action been taken
i know a while back on the twitter page
there was a few enforcement actions um
on there and that was really helpful for
us to relay back to
residents especially residents who had
picked out specific fly tipping and
reported that so yeah if you could
answer that for me i would
that would be great thanks okay
um you have a question
uh yes first of all a comment on
removing targets as a quote i heard
many years ago was uh you don't make a
thing longer by measuring it so
i think yes i agree with that um just
something on the re
the reduced frequency of reporting
presumably your meaning reporting to the
council
and if you're reducing the frequency do
you know roughly
how long that would be that would that
be once a year and you said you're
moving to live data
um how often would that be refreshed
would that be daily or weekly or what
okay that's all thank you very much for
your report as well hannah
okay um councillor huxley
thanks chair thanks hannah for your
report i've got three suggestions for
the indicators
um you're saying the tree one number of
trees removed and planted on tdc open
spaces
can you add hedges or hedgerows to that
um in the media recently they said the
hedges provide
just as much um biodiversity as trees or
even more
number two the recycling rates
percentage of waste recycled
can we have a percentage of recycled
waste in than
center incineration again that's another
thing that's been a big issue recently
in the media
and number three tdc greenhouse gas
emissions
can we add a sort of uh amount of co2
emissions from all
tdc council houses thanks i mean you've
been talking about rtc public buildings
but
housing i think's a big issue as well
thanks
okay thank you um councillor piper
thank you chair i'd just like to thank
hannah for her very comprehensive report
um very very impressive i'd like to
volunteer my services for helping out
on the website um and actually counselor
um roper covered what i was
going to ask about the frequency of
updating the website
that was it thanks very much hannah
okay counselor boyd
thank you chair and thank you hannah and
nathaniel for your report
um it was just a quick question um
regarding i thought the complaints
is listed as one of the indicators
in terms of what has been measured it's
just simply number of
um would it be helpful to have a
timeline of
complaints being measured in terms of
how quickly they're dealt with
or indeed um things like queries and
stuff like so how our response time
whether it's via the website via twitter
via facebook
so our response time because i think
that's quite important to residents
obviously in the previous
set of indicators we had call time
response and so i was just wondering
would we have something like that
because that
very much means quite a lot to residents
[Music]
okay um i can't see any other members at
the moment if you've got any
uh queries please indicate in the chat
i've got a couple of questions and
comments um it
it it probably singles me out as
old-fashioned but
um rather than welcome the removal of
targets
as councillor wrote for thus i'm a
little bit concerned that that can
actually be a way of sort of sliding
away from things that maybe aren't
currently
looking quite so good um you know it's
fine that you're going to have a
qualitative measure rather than
quantitative
but who decides the quality you know i
mean it still seems to me essentially
that
somebody somewhere has to be making some
value judgment as to
what an acceptable level would be so
i'll
be interested in in a few more thoughts
around that
um you said that uh which we're all
aware of that the resident survey
um forms the basis for a lot of the
feedback that we get from the public
and i wonder if you could just remind us
how many
how many people are approached how many
respond
and do we have any idea how the
demographic
of the surveyed group matches the
demographic of the district
um what else oh yeah um it's great that
everything's going to go on the website
and it's going to be all singing and
dancing and that is
great progress it will only be
worthwhile if it's really used so what
plans have you got to encourage
traffic to the website and to that
particular bit of it
um you know because it's fine we've got
it all there but if
if people aren't going to it then it's
not really doing too much
um i think it's essential that
uh you know we table now that perhaps in
12 months time we have a real critical
review
of the whole thing i mean i know we're
going to be looking at it an ongoing
basis
but i think we we should have uh
diarized if you like
uh at a time when we will actually say
well okay this is what you said we were
going to do
this is what we've done this is how the
public reacted to it
has it worked or you know hopefully
it'll be yes and and how can we improve
it i definitely think we
we need to do that um i'm also
interested that
um a number of the things uh in the
uh the measures
um we're talking about uh we're
measuring things by public opinion you
know we've got resident survey opinion
of parks and open spaces
recycling service and whatever um
i mean are they all annual surveys and
if they are
is that adequate or maybe should we find
a way for that to be a more
rolling survey rather than as it is
um one thing i think is really good i
mean i think it's good that we're
recording how many bins percentage bins
we collect rather than the percentage we
miss
um i've been banging on about that for
years because i think our service is
brilliant
um you know and we should be really
celebrating that um
so i i think that's that's probably
about it
for my comments you've got lots of other
comments there kaneki
and tim and nate nathaniel between you
can you answer as many of those as you
can
absolutely very happy and you know what
i'm such a sado that
these are really brilliant questions
they're so good i can see nathaniel's
been smiling away as well so
um we were all kind of we're all on the
same page with this i think
um i think i'm going to take them in
that just means you fooled us hannah
[Laughter]
again
right okay i'm going to try and i think
i've captured everything that we needed
to cover so going in reverse
so public opinion you are exactly right
um and our reliance on an annual
residence service
it's a brilliant exercise for having a
snapshot of a moment in time from a
random selection
of people that would otherwise probably
be disengaged for the council
and i think that is an excellent tool
for that but that's all it is
and what we need to move more towards is
supplementing that with customer
satisfaction survey so
the resident survey is kind of our
annual snapshot
what we are doing as part of this
process is putting pressure on the
services
to do far more frequent checking in with
their customers
and we can if this is something that
scrutiny would be interested in we could
be quite prescriptive and we can
capture how often each of the services
are going to be doing that and
what that looks like and to make sure
that you're kind of satisfied that
that's a robust enough
mechanism but yeah absolutely they are
two distinct things
and i certainly don't want i think
before we've relied on the annual
residence survey
to be more than it actually is and so
that's kind of that's where we are with
that once we're on the same page there
and the 12-month review absolutely um i
i would want to be testing it and making
sure
and that it's working in a way that
scrutiny find it acceptable
to be analyzing the analytics and the
analytics
and this is again one of the great
things of having us on the website is
we've got all of that access to
information that our fingertip
fingertips we will be able to see the
areas and the measures particularly that
get the higher click rates
and the things that um people are kind
of more fascinated by
and we can then in turn use that data to
then make more improvements
and that in itself absolutely has to go
hand in hand with
better promotion so as part of this once
we've finalized the approach
and we've got it in place you are
exactly right i can't imagine
many people if any are going to just
randomly search oh performance data at
some
council on our website and navigate
their way there and we absolutely have
to promote that
and that will be part of the
communications activity and once we've
got that in place
and what we've got next residence survey
so in terms of the the kind of the
mechanics of how that works
yes you're right it's an annual survey
it was slightly late this year
as a result of um our covered response
but it's gone out we've turned that
around quite quickly
and we've got we're currently analyzing
the data now i'm pleased to confirm
and we've got the higher response rate
than we've had in the last
five years which is great it's gone up
every year we've got more
responses i don't want to get too
excited because we're still talking
around the 1000 mark
um so you know we're not it kind of it's
not staggering
but in terms of kind of from a
statistical point of view that's an
average rate it's one in six
because we go out um to six thousand
randomly selected residents
um and that kind of level of response
rate in terms of an industry standard
is good that's exactly what you would
expect to be getting
and achieving so i'm really pleased with
that um
we'll be sharing those results with you
um very soon
um because we delayed it slightly then i
was really keen to make sure that we
communicate the results to that quite
quickly
i mean in terms of how we determine who
we go out to it's a random selection
but it is based on postcode area so that
we can then
make sure we target proportionally
the number of areas so we're kind of
making sure that we're going out
um to people in in this kind of a
variety of different areas as possible
um other demographics we've stopped
recording
so government guidance changed um and
the guidance nowadays in relation to
capturing personal data
is unless you critically need to be
gathering that data
and you can argue as to why you need
that data then you shouldn't be asking
it
um i do wonder whether that's something
that maybe we can test
because i think it would be helpful
particularly to know kind of maybe age
range
in in addition to postcode um
and maybe there's some other factors
that would really help and we would be
able to demonstrate that
it's important to understand that
demographic
because it might mean that we've got to
change the way we're delivering that
service to that particular group
um but hopefully that gives kind of a
you know enough of a steer on how we do
that
how do you make a value judgment about
good performance my goodness
how long have we got um nathaniel and i
have done a lot of research around this
um moving away from
from targets is kind of it's
becoming more common practice this is
something that businesses the world over
now are moving towards
and trying to understand quality over
and above kind of quantity
and you still need to have that quantity
to understand that you're delivering
the service in the way that you'd be
expecting but it's it's as i was saying
in the presentation about
kind of understanding the impact of what
you're doing and that is around
more of the kind of the opinion side so
our starting point is going to be just
to share that data with you and say
and i think our benchmark will be
numbers of people satisfied
versus numbers of people who aren't
satisfied i think that's going to be our
benchmark
um i think my problem with attaching
targets to that and i think
i'm pretty sure it was councillor
campbell that asked me um
or made this comment um in previous
scrutiny meeting about well surely
around satisfaction shouldn't your
target be 100
because arguably you want to give
everyone an amazing service um so i
think that's kind of
where what we're trying to do and we
just need to be open and upfront and
share with people kind of what
people's opinions are of us eat you know
the good the bad on the ugly
um in relation to complaints from
councillor boyd
um nathaniel and i were discussing this
um earlier
today and we're not sure that just
showing the number of complaints
really does it um i'm not sure that it
does and we spoke
with the team who are responsible for
capturing all
council correspondents and because of
the way that it's monitored there isn't
an
obvious way to be able to reflect
accurately
response rates to all of the different
kind of correspondence that goes on
we've got service requests we've got
complaints
we have fois we have compliments even
and that does happen
um but yeah there's not a clear kind of
obvious way
about how we can record it any
differently than
how we are currently sharing it in terms
of complaint numbers um
but i think that needs some work and i
hear that and i think maybe we do need
to go away and come up with something
that's a bit better
um which gives more of a demonstration
of how efficient we're being
um we could we did previously report on
the on response rate in terms
of telephone calls received through
customer services if that's something
that feels like in the absence of there
being
any other kind of obvious way then i
would be happy to continue to share that
we can absolutely add that back in and
you know be good
to hear kind of a comeback response to
that um
in term thank you councillor piper for
your offer of helping um
with the website i think it would be
really good and as councillor bates said
yeah it's not kind of
it's absolutely no slight on you to be
asking for your opinion
um it's just i think it would be helpful
as kind of people that are slightly more
engaged with this process if you're
finding that this isn't quite doing it
for you then i think
we're getting something wrong so i would
be keen to
understand that very early on um whoever
got to
um councillor huxley and all of your
suggestions
i think for some of these i'm going to
need to go back and test
whether the services are actually
capturing this data and so you mentioned
about hedges and hedgerows
the recycling rates um instead what we
sent for incineration
and our co2 from all council housing
properties i don't i'm going to put
nathaniel a bit on the spot i don't know
nathaniel whether you know that that's
something that's captured currently any
of those things
okay i'm going to try so the
incineration
for recycling and because ken are the
disposal
authority um those figures would
probably be something that
that ken county council would have
access to and wouldn't necessarily
reflect how
are dealing with the ways it's their
their role to
actually uh dispose of voice
rather than the collection of the
recycling
um for the other ones i think we do need
to go back to the services and
see if it has been captured
thanks nathaniel and i was just going to
add on that just because
some of the data isn't necessarily um
information that we hold and report on
ourselves there's no reason why we
couldn't for example within the context
of that indicator
include links to the websites or the web
pages
of the other agencies who are recording
that kind of data and just to try to be
kind of more helpful we'd have to be
really clear that we weren't giving
the impression then that we're owning
that and responsible for it
but actually if that's something that's
useful and interesting to people why
wouldn't we want to kind of
make it easier for them to find out more
information about that i think it's a
really good suggestion
and we'll come back to you um in
relation to the other suggestions
because i think
if that's stuff that we capture and we
can include it then there's no reason
why we shouldn't
um council europa in relation to
um how often we're going to be
refreshing data again i'm gonna
hand over to nathaniel but just from my
perspective um
nathaniel is amazing at what he does um
i don't know embarrassing nathaniel but
you are and actually one of the
one of the things that we are doing as
part of this process is making sure that
from
the kind of the back office side of
things is having all of our internal
systems
um talking to our website so the idea is
to automate it so that the data can be
pulled from our system
and then automatically populated into
the website and the dream with that
is that that means that that can be done
on a really regular basis
um but it might be again that you want
um excuse me panel members
particular assurance then what we could
do is maybe record
for each of the indicators we're
capturing we can make it clear on the
website how frequently that that is
refreshed to make sure that we've been
really transparent about that nathaniel
was there anything all you wanted to add
on that
um i don't think so too much it's just
that's unfortunate i think nathaniel was
potentially frozen
um i will continue when nathaniel
reappears then i might jump back to him
and counselor oprah the other question
you asked was in relation to
the frequency of reporting um
i think that's completely down to you as
to um how often
you would you would like that um i'm
very happy to come as often as you want
um but i think probably every six months
feels from kind of giving a corporate
perspective feels about right
and but in the meantime because you're
going to have access to this data
all of the time if there are particular
services or particular indicators that
are worrying you
or that you think you're doing really
well and you would then be
completely welcome to invite the
different service members
and that represent those areas to come
and then explain a little bit more
from a service perspective and then you
can ask loads of really difficult
in-depth questions and put them on the
spot
and they'll be able to answer it then
and there um that's
that's the kind of plan but i think we
were really hoping and i'm hoping that
this is something that
um pleases nick as well this is this is
trying to make the best use of
scrutiny's time and
the best use of the function of scrutiny
and being able to hold
particular people to account that's you
know again one of the things that we're
really hoping to achieve with this and
nathaniel you look like you're moving
can i jump back
um yeah
it's gone again
this is just a bit of a light relief to
try and uh brighten the mood of it
and it's ironic that he's the technical
wizard as well isn't it
it's really rather unfortunate
at least he's frozen smiling though
that's good this is true
okay i am very close to the start of the
question
so um counselor curry asked in relation
to enforcement actions
um and activity this is definitely
something that we know is important to
local people we we
will still be capturing that enforcement
absolutely will be reported
um again i'm kind of happy to with the
table that we share we can
give a bit more information in relation
to actually what that breakdown looks
like what that includes
um and how frequently that will be
reported but yes it is something that
as you pointed out on social media we're
trying to drive
more and communications around that
because we want to demonstrate that
we're you know being really proactive as
a council
and then the final question then or the
first one however you look at it um
which was from council
more in relation to this time scale of
six months um
around the housing indicator i don't
know the answer i'm afraid
um so i thought i'd be honest
again i don't know again no one reason
if i knew you you are moving again i
might try one last time
um the very first question that came in
in relation to property um the time
scales
um is that something that you're able to
help out with so with the time scales
obviously we need to be sensible for
annual surveys
we're not going to update that on a
daily basis
where data is available on a more
frequent basis
we'll make sure that we can get that
updated um
but we're working with services to make
sure we've got a schedule of when
they will be updating their data or it's
available
and i think again it'd be sensible to
share what that schedule
is when the time's right
okay thanks nathaniel um tim sorry if i
ignored your hand for a while
you want to say something so tim did you
want to come in
um i was just going to say what i know
about the six-month rule
on empties um it's the sort of industry
standard
it's typically when people talk about
long-term entities first sort of
managing
stock generally is six months um
there are some there's some statutory
con powers that local authority have um
under the housing act that that action
can be triggered after six months
empty property subject to certain
conditions
and also we had an empty properties
project who's government funded it's all
finished now but
that was all subject to empty properties
longer than six months we could take
action with
we bought them and turn them back into
the stock so
i think there's general sort of
acceptance as to why it's six months
and just while while i have air time i
just wanted to agree with the chair
um i i don't want to be presumptuous but
i think
if you're an analytical mind then when
people talk about
qualitative and outcomes then you begin
to worry
that things aren't being measured um and
and i have some sympathy with that but i
think because we're
we have offered some baselining um and
that will be informed by benchmarking
it does mean that we're not just looking
at the fanuc bubble and look only
comparing our performance
in the eyes of a few people that we ask
um
on the basis of our past performance
because if our past performance was
really bad
and our performance now is just bad that
doesn't mean we're doing well enough
so we will still have um some measures
of our performance against others
yeah yeah i mean i think that's a very
valid point i mean one of the things
that i've written down and forgot to ask
was the fact that
you know we used back in the day we used
to have
other authorities that we saw as kind of
mirror images of ourselves didn't we we
used to compare
statistics with them and i wondered
whether the days of that have totally
gone or whether there's any value in
that
um and also while you're comprehensively
answering all the questions
hannah i've thought of a couple more
sorry um
that the first is that um
you originally we we had the the three
categories communities environment
growth and you've added
efficiency but in those growth is
seriously underrepresented there's only
two
sort of items of growth so i wonder if
there's going to be anything done about
that
because that seems a bit inadequate and
the other thing was that going right
back to the start of the presentation
um you pointed out that residents put
thr having thriving towns in their top
three
and i can't see really any indicators in
here or measures
that reflect that particularly so i
wonder whether that's something that
needs looking at
i think both of those points are
absolutely spot-on and
they we acknowledge that and i'm
be delighted to take that feedback back
to the relevant services and to put a
bit of pressure on
and i think the problem is um with some
of those measures i think the council
resource is predominantly around
particular projects and that is part of
the projects that you have behind your
own
performance mechanisms as part of that
um
we don't have for example you know an
economic development
section of the council anymore and so i
think um
this is an area definitely um where it
was less obvious where we could go to
for some of that
information and but that doesn't mean
that we shouldn't be capturing some of
that i can see tim
waving at me uh can i just
just before i bring tim in uh counselor
paul moore you've raised the hand
no soy chair that was the sausage finger
that did that unfortunately okay
all right i apologize okay i'm assuming
tim that yours wasn't sausage finger no
i left it out far too long but then i
put it out put it up again
um i'm just um conscious that i might be
channeling my cabinet number my
portfolio holder a little bit but
um it is in our corporate priorities and
community wealth building might be an
area where
that we could add something in under the
growth category i'm not sure
what and how we'd collect data but that
might be an area that the council might
want to consider
yeah i think that's very valid okay okay
on behalf of the panel uh can i thank
you hannah and nathaniel for very
comprehensive presentation and answering
the questions
uh thank you tim for a bit of clarity
around some of the things um
i think uh you've gathered from this
meeting that
we're very supportive of it i think it's
very positive uh
step forward um and i think i just asked
the panel to to note the report
that we've got before us today and again
to get the commitment from
you guys that you will take away the
suggestions that we've made
and incorporate them in you know what's
clearly still a work in progress but it
looks very impressive and i'm sure we
look forward to being a great success so
thank you very much
members um officers that concludes the
meeting so thank you very much for
attending
and goodbye